david bonjour les manifestants ont-ils
répondu à l'appel et le cortège est il
parti amira le cortège va partir dans
quelques instants mais oui la réponse
est oui les manifestants ont répondu
présent pour cette mobilisation qu'on
peut qualifier de dernière chance
puisque le projet de loi de réforme des
retraites est présenté aujourd'hui au
ministre avant son examen final mi
février à l'assemblée nationale
juste un instant un flashmob s'est mis
en place ici place de la république par
plusieurs femmes qui ont effectué ce
flashmob pour interpeller et agnel macro
ans sur ce projet de loi de réforme
aurait fait je me trouve justement avec
claire un char l'aise qui fait partie de
l'association féministe des effrontées
pourquoi c'est important pour vous
d'être là aujourd'hui et d'avoir
justement effectué cette chorégraphie
pour interpeller le gouvernement d'
emmanuel macron c'est important parce
qu'on voit que pour l'instant il reste
campé sur ses positions
alors que nous on réclame tout
simplement le retrait de la réforme et
on continuera jusqu'au retrait
c'est important pour les femmes parce
qu'en fait les femmes sont les premières
perdantes
contrairement à ce qu'a dit edouard
philippe conte seraient les premières
gagnantes
on sait très bien que c'est totalement
faux et on continuera jusqu'à ce qu'ils
comprennent ce qu'on le message qu'on
essaie de lui faire passer le fait que
le texte soit présenté aujourd'hui au
ministre est ce que c'est une motivation
supplémentaire pour vous oui c'est une
motivation supplémentaire parce que là
pour l'instant justement il ne
s'écoutent absolument pas tout ce qu'on
dit depuis le début nous qu'est ce qu'on
dit des choses simples en fait cette
réforme ne peut être bénéfique a
absolument personne
simplement parce que mathématiquement à
partir du moment où on prend l'ensemble
de la carrière pour calculer la pension
contrairement à aux 25 meilleures années
dans le privé auparavant et aux six
derniers mois dans le public ça ne peut
que mathématiquement c'est à baisser les
pensions de tout le monde après les
femmes le problème par rapport aux
femmes c'est que l ont des carrières qui
sont plus haché il faut savoir que 80 %
des temps partiels sont occupés par des
femmes
il faut savoir que presque d'un un tiers
des femmes est à temps partiel contre 8
% des hommes
donc forcément les femmes du fait de ces
carrières hachées déjà en des pensions
qui sont dues
moindre aujourd'hui l'écart des pensions
entre les femmes et les hommes est
énorme il de 42% c c'est absolument
énorme et ça va encore s'accroître avec
cette réforme
donc nous on continuera à lutter
jusqu'au retrait de cette réforme qui
est totalement inique et qui va encore
plus pénaliser les femmes
quand on parle de mobilisation la
dernière chance aujourd'hui qu'est ce
que ça vous inspire
oui c'est une façon de dire que c'est
presque fini en fait sauf que nous non
c'est pas vrai le mouvement
s'essoufflait pas comme ont très bien
dit bah l'ensemble des camarades des
dessins des syndicats etc
en fait non s'essouffle pas on reprend
le souffle tout simplement pour repartir
de plus belle
donc non le certes ils ont déterminé je
pense merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à
nos questions clés charlès voilà en tout
cas un important dispositif de sécurité
était mis en place un dispositif de
sécurité assez impressionnant a dit
l'allemand a prévenu qu'il allait mettre
tous les moyens matériels et humains
pour pouvoir assurer la sécurité des
manifestants mais surtout pour éviter
des violences et dégradations comme il
ya pu y avoir durant les dernières
manifestations